You're a student and what's your name
brother?
>> My name is
>> some fairy.
>> His name is fair.
>> Ferry.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Okay. Ferry. What's your question?
>> I have a question.
>> You're most welcome.
>> And we know that God is just a spirit.
But in Muslim
they believe in the prophet Muhammad
and all we are created by one God.
In my belief I know that prophet
Muhammad is just a man
which means Muham prophet Muhammad
and all of us we are created by God.
What the main difference?
>> Can the brother repeat this? The person
behind
>> ask me the question.
>> Can you repeat the question?
>> Ask me the question. Ask me ask me the
question.
>> Question.
>> The microphone is the speaker is not
very clear.
>> Mhm.
>> My brother's name is Felix.
>> Phelix.
>> Felix. Felix.
>> Felix.
>> Yes. Correct. He's asking
he knows Prophet Muhammad. He is a human
being like us.
>> Yes. And as Muslim we all believe in him
while he's a normal person created like
us. And in Christianity they know God as
a spirit.
>> Correct.
>> Yeah.
>> So he wants to be elaborated in that to
be explained why Muslim follow Prophet
Muhammad.
>> The brother asked a very good question
>> and all of us were created by one God.
The brother has the question that he
knows that in Islam,
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him is a
man
>> and God is a spirit. So why do we follow
a man? Brother, no Muslim considers
Prophet Muhammad to be God. There's a
difference between God and a messenger
of God. So what we call Prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him is messenger of God
and not God. He is a human being but a
special human being.
>> Prophet Muhammad is a human being peace
be upon him but almighty God chooses him
amongst the other human being to deliver
the message to mankind.
So prophet Muhammad is the last and
final messenger of almighty God which
was
sent as a messenger to the whole of
humanity. All the earlier messengers
that came Adam, Abraham, Moses, Jesus
peace be upon them all, they were sent
only for their people and for a
particular time period. But because
Prophet Muhammad was the last and final
messenger, he was not sent only for the
Muslims or the Arabs. He was sent for
the whole of humanity, for all the
world. So that is the difference between
Prophet Muhammad and the other
messengers. But Prophet Muhammad, no
Muslim worships him. No Muslim considers
to him to be God. He's the messenger of
God. Hope the answers the question.
>> Maybe another question.
>> My brother,
he has another question.
>> Okay. My brother Samuel is asking in
Christianity they all know that there
are many prophets before Muhammad but
why do those old prophets stand before
Muhammad?
Why do we Muslims don't follow all other
prophets except Muhammad?
>> All the prophets of God we respect, we
love and we believe. We believe all the
messengers, all the prophets of God were
sent by God by Allah. We respect them
all. But the difference between prophet
Muhammad and the other messengers as I
mentioned earlier all the other prophets
was sent for a particular group of
people. Moses was sent only for the
Jews. Jesus Christ peace be upon him
according to Gospel of Matthew chapter
number 10 verse number 5-6 Jesus Christ
says go ye not into the way of the
Gentiles tells his disciples go ye not
to the non-Jews
enter not into the city of the
Samaritans but rather go to the house of
the lost sheep of Israel so Jesus Christ
peace be upon him tells his disciples
only give the message to the Jews it
further mentioned in The gospel of
Matthew chapter number 15 verse number
24 that I have not been sent but to the
lost sheep of the house of Israel. So
all the prophets that came before
prophet Muhammad peace be upon him was
sent only for a particular group of
people. But since prophet Muhammad was
the last and final messenger peace be
upon him. He was not sent only for the
Muslims or the Arabs. Allah says in
surah chapter number 21 verse number 107
that we have sent thee not BUT AS A
MERCY TO ALL THE worlds as a mercy to
all the creatures as a mercy to the
whole of humanity. That's the reason
prophet Muhammad peace be upon him has
been prophesized in the scriptures of
the major world religion. He's
prophesized in the Hindu scripture. He's
prophesized in the Vedas in the
upanishad. is prophesized in the Jewish
scripture and I gave a talk Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam in the Bible
in the Old Testament is prophesized in
the book of Deuteronomy chapter number
18 verse number 18 in the book of
Deuteronomy chapter number 18 verse
number 19 in the book of Deuteronomy
chapter number 18 verse number 20 is
prophesized in the book of Isaiah
chapter number 29 verse number 12 is
prophesized in the song of Solomon
chapter 5 verse number 16 is prophesized
in the book of Isaiah chapter number 42
verse number 1 to 11 is prophesized in
the New Testament in the Gospel of John
chapter number 14:16 Gospel of John
chapter number 15:26 Gospel of John
chapter number 16 verse number 7 Gospel
of John chapter number 16 verse number
12 to 14 he said I have many things to
say unto you but he cannot bear them now
for he when the spirits of truth shall
come he shall guide you unto all truth
he shall not speak of himself all that
hear shall he speak all these prophecies
refer to no one but the last and final
messenger so because he was the last and
final messenger all the earlier prophets
prophets even prophet Jesus peace be
upon him he prophesizes
the coming of prophet Muhammad. So that
is the difference between
So that is the difference between
prophet Muhammad and the earlier
messengers. Hope you understand.
>> Brother, do you believe that there's one
God?
>> Yeah. Yes.
>> Do you believe there's one God?
>> Yes. Do you believe that Jesus is a
messenger of God?
>> Yeah.
>> Do you believe that Prophet Muhammad is
a messenger of God?
>> Yeah.
>> Mashallah. Then you're a Muslim. If you
believe in these two things that
there is one God and you believe that
Prophet Muhammad is the messenger of
God, you're a Muslim.
>> Just a last question on that before then
I agree.
>> Yeah.
Can you just repeat it brother in the
pink shirt? Can you repeat it?
>> Here's the last question.
>> One more question. Okay, you're most
welcome. We have seen
>> brother Felix is asking
all religion have prophets. The
Christian had prophet and the Muslim
have prophets.
>> Why do we have the differences then?
>> Yeah. And we also we serve one God.
>> Why do we have the differences and we
all serve one God?
>> All the prophets taught the same thing.
believe in one God and worship HIM. BUT
THE PEOPLE CHANGE THEIR MESSAGE. TODAY'S
BIBLE that you have is a changed form.
It's not the original word of God. The
original word that was received that was
revealed to Jesus is correct. But the
present Bible is a mixture. It contains
the word of God. It contains the word of
prophet. It contains the word of
historian. It even contains pornography.
Now because Bible wasn't meant to be
followed by everyone, God did not think
it fit to preserve it. But because Quran
is supposed to be followed by the whole
world and since Quran is supposed to
stay till eternity till the last day,
Almighty God says in the Quran in surah
hijar chapter number 15 verse number 9,
I have revealed the Quran AND I SHALL
GUARD FROM CORRUPTION. So this Quran
there is no adulteration pure
because prophet Muhammad is the last
messenger and the Quran is meant for the
whole world. So that's the difference
between the Quran and the Bible.
So do you believe there's one God?
>> Yeah.
>> Do you believe Prophet Muhammad is a
messenger of God?
>> Yes.
>> Do you want to say it in Arabic?
>> I will say it and you can repeat it.
>> Yes.
>> Ashu.
Repeat what he's saying. I shall do
>> I shall
>> I shall do
>> Allah
>> illahillah
>> illallah
>> illallahu
>> shala
>> ana
>> muhamadan
>> abdu
>> father
>> I bear witness
>> that
>> there is no god
>> but Allah
>> and I bear witness witness
>> and I bear witness
>> that Prophet Muhammad
>> peace be upon him peace be upon him
>> be upon him
>> is the messenger
>> and servant
>> and so
>> of Allah
>> mashallah you're a Muslim
>> I would like to congratulate YOU
>> mashallah welcome to the fold of Islam
you have joined a family of 2 billion
Muslims and inshallah once you accept
Islam all your previous sins have been
forgiven. I pray to Allah subhanana wa
ta'ala to give you the best in this
world and a